Martha Stewart is the only woman to  drink you under the table  Shh Thanks really Edmund a racehorse  were drinking oh my god you would love  it I bet I would everything about it it  will get her on untold stories tell the  stories about you she's probably got her  penitentiary story so like I had no  problems in there I had all the girls  we're bringing me all kind of noodles  and chips and stuff that I didn't even  want like it was both bawling in there  Martha Martha Stewart is the only woman  to drink you under the table  Shh Thanks really Edmund a racehorse  we're drinking  oh my god you would love I bet I would  everything about it if we get her on  untold stories tell the stories about  you she's probably got her penitentiary  story seems like I had no problems in  there I had all the girls on we're  bringing me all kinds of noodles and  chips and stuff and I didn't even want  like it was both bawling in there Martha  you